women what do they want it's it's a
question that's plates no less an
authority than movie star and noted
humanitarian Mel Gibson not to be
confused with his far less successful
follow-up why are Jews but for most
American women one thing they might want
is to be paid the same as men and one
prominent man currently agrees women
deserve equal pay for equal work
equal pay kicked off your presidency
it's become really a theme one of the
themes of your time here well that's
nice equal pay is not such a bad theme
it's certainly an improvement of the
previous presidential themes including
let's lock up all the Japanese and
destroy the seminal scourge
unfortunately as is so often the case
for this president his laudable goal was
muddled right from the outset today the
average full-time working woman earns
just 77 cents for every dollar a man
earns equal pay for equal work it's not
that complicated yeah it shouldn't be
that complicated and as long as he
hasn't overlooked something which
complicates this significantly
everything should still be on track in
2013 female staffers in the Obama White
House were paid less than 88 cents for
every dollar paid to male staffers well
that's okay that's okay maybe that just
means the president was 88% sincere when
he talked about equal pay which if you
rounded up is basically a hundred
percent anyway so why is everyone
complaining and with that all anyone
could focus on was not how to fix this
problem but how to quantify it the labor
department itself the president's own
labor department says it's 81 cents
another federal study for example says
the disparity is more like 88 cents for
every dollar the studies do show that
when you do the controlling there's
about a nine percent gap the wage gap is
really somewhere between five and seven
cents women who do not get married have
virtually no wage gap they are in 96
cents for every dollar a man
max look even if 96 cents is the number
which it isn't it's still terrible let
me put this in terms that are perhaps
easy to understand if someone takes a
dump on my desk the size of the dump is
not the issue how big of a dump is it 8
inches 10 inches just 3 inches well
that's almost like you didn't take a
dump on my desk this is where we are
right now the one Equal Pay Act in
Congress has already been killed and
there is seemingly nothing on the
horizon but to listen to some that's not
a problem because not only does the gap
barely exist if it does it's actually
woman's fault
women make different choices about what
kinds of jobs they seek they make
different choices in reaction to
marriage and childbirth when those
things those factors are taken into
consideration studies have indicated
that the pay gap all but evaporates
classic women have paid less because
they choose to have children or that
although to be fair they didn't
technically choose to be the sole gender
biologically capable of pregnancy with
the notable exception of course of
seahorses and Arnold Schwarzenegger and
jr. that just let's be balanced here the
second popular argument for why the wage
gap is woman's fault is that they choose
to enter lower paying professions when
you compare men and women in the same
positions and this with the same
experience the same education there
there is no pay gap you need to look at
yes what the what the position is and
you need to compare apples to apples not
pick and choose ok apples waffles ok
well in which case I actually have a
question for you
how do you like these apples a recent
study out of Yale University that is
interesting where professors were given
the identical resume one was had the
name John on the top and one had the
name Jennifer on top and the male
candidate was rated more favorably
they were offered on average four
thousand dollars more than the female
candidate
okay okay so it seems we either address
the root of this problem and fight
entrenched sexism in our society or all
women simply change their names to John
it'll be confusing for a while but
you'll have $4,000 extra a year just to
take the edge off the confusion and also
don't despair just yet because
apparently if women can just hang in
there there is hope if you're unmarried
and childless between the age of 35 and
43 the the statistics show you make a
dollar eight on average to every male
dollar so there you have it ladies if
you can just remain single not
accidentally have children and never
turn 44 you're gonna be golden less for
the same work is clearly wrong even
monkeys know that scientists actually
ran a test where two monkeys performed
exactly the same task one was paid with
a grape and the other with just a
cucumber watch how the monkey who got
the cucumber reacted it was underpaid
you don't know what the other monkeys
experience in education were it just
made different choices in your life
besides a cucumber is virtually the same
as a grape now some people are always
going to want to pay women less even if
it is let's say 83 cents on the dollar
but if we're not going to get
legislation it should at least be
obvious who is choosing to do that so to
that end we would like to suggest this
are you a middle-aged man running a
financial firm or a multinational
conglomerate do you find that pushy
female employees have been nagging you
with unreasonable demands for equal pay
what if I told you about a revolutionary
new product that lets you pay women just
as much as men without sacrificing the
sheer convenience of paying them less
introducing ladybucks
dollars for female employees that are
worth just 83 cents on the dollar
lady bucks is the new currency for women
from the Federal Reserve and the
creators of Playtex gentle glide 360
available in a variety of colors and
scents ladybucks feature America's most
celebrated female presidents like Geena
Davis Julia Louie Dreyfus and Battlestar
Galactica slower Lazar who only became
president after almost all of mankind
was destroyed it's an amount that could
be described as virtually the same
really just reflective of the different
choices women make and some dub Mad Men
so why not try ladybugs show
the women in your workplace that they're
truly 0.83 in a million ladybugs are not
for everyone
consult your lawyer before using
ladybugs use of ladybugs may result in
class-action lawsuits adverse publicity
failure to retain staff or being kicked
in the dick
[Applause]